[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale jatropha son journal
oublierez nouvelle j'espère qu'elle
trouve ça super voyage remporté à la
ceiba le zimbawe sur qu'outil des petits
commérages eu de très grosses auteur est
le petit écho de la forêt ces intrus
vrai serrez vous la verrez il y à toutes
les informations à chaque nouvelle
édition on n'a jamais de déception ça
vous le découvrirez dans l'homme tu t'es
cours de l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons voyons quelles sont les
surprises que nous réserve d'autres
jours nomme au cou et coûter cher
téléphone
isadora a eu une bonne initiative que
tutu comble en tous cas moi je les paie
pas restée inactive cultive des légumes
à ses démons couper des quelque chose
d'original
tu ne trouveras jamais ma peau on roule
me connais pas aussi c'est ainsi qu'ils
s'adoraient moi c'est vous va très bien
avec des plumes violettes et vertes
vous gardez l'esprit je me trouve très
bien comme je suis ma il me faut des
clients vous ouvrez un commerce une
salon on aura tout vu
isadora continue à chercher une
clientèle pour son futur salon de
coiffure je veux pas te défrise able to
soleil sur l'île avec des boucles en
question comme ça tu m'as max il y avait
des teintes de l'épreuve blanc et les
fans encore bon boulot ça ne s'est
jamais vous verra jamais vu des morts
avez-vous on est paysan d inventer des
certains disent à doha couru toute la
forêt mais personne ne voulait croire à
l'utilité de son salon de coiffure ainsi
bolus iata pas très bien refuser come on
ou tel ou mage et moutons et moi pas
vouloir manger moi alors il y avait
notamment salon de coiffure mccovey ce
faire comme moi
mieux il possible moi il faut que c'est
magique kitimat coupe qui se voit du
même de quoi parle t on quand il était
comme ça triste j'ai voyagé beaucoup ya
l'homme contre les pays science était à
bout ça alors toi faire venir tout le
monde at-on maison et aussi tous qu'ils
s'adoraient se précipita chez les frères
tu as tort ça c'est une bonne idée mais
s'il part il n'y a que toi pour avoir
des idées pareilles
alors vous allez vite vous mettre au
travail il me faut des tables des
chaises on bat deux états l unja bon et
tout et tout c'est tout nancy n'est pas
tout il faille et vous facilite hier et
pas des mains pour une idée c'est une
bonne idée les sites et maryse à doha à
une bonne ici native ans dit initiative
whi autrement dit elle a eu une bonne
idée
il aura à hugo et des ah oui elle a eu
une bonne et ciani tir et enfin je veux
dire qu'elle a une bonne idée ou et
figure toi zip
dès qu'il a pris l'initiative qui
avaient fui sa de ghazi parti comme une
flèche chez mademoiselle de la cigogne
incroyable d'être ici at il dit nous il
déroule devant souhaite a en tout cas je
n'irai jamais pourquoi maison enfin mon
pauvre zip et vous me voyez en entrée de
zone bistrot visa n'est pas aberrant
c'est trop bistrot où je n'ai pas
habiteront c'est un endroit où pour
nourrir tous pour bavarder en virant en
tête et judokas ventes honda abricots
j'ai horreur des caveaux que les
abricots arrive alors à mademoiselle
dans la rigole pense à corps et vous
avez eu pour une fois une bonne
initiative que la science est bon pour
anvers mais allez dans votre barre
pâquis une demoiselle de mon rang ne se
rend pas dans un bar disons alors un
café il ne s'agit pas de café non plein
maison enfin c'est un endroit il a bien
non oui si c'est là où le club un club
préfère fan club dont six conditions si
c'est un club un club a plus de classe
eh bien c'est dit j'irai dans notre club
mais oui cette chaire isadora a eu une
excellente initiative de créer un club
dans notre forêt cela manquait n'est ce
pas cher telle est one
1 et club